and fly into Cleveland and I go do Theo
Von's podcast Theo's telling me hey this
theater is weird during my opening act I
feel like something's a little off about
this place and all a sudden I started to
hear this like rumbling above my head it
sounds like a roller coaster is
going on above my head and then I
started to hear electrical sounds like
Sparks and 10 minutes into my set almost
exactly I'm telling a joke that I'm very
proud of that I'm excited to hear the
response of the crowd and right as I get
to the punchline I hear like a loud snap
and all everything goes silent lights go
out and everyone's like we we don't have
anything we can do the whole block is
out power-wise tell them that the show's
canceled and they get a mic working that
like you can only use this for
announcements and they hand it to me and
I I'm like guys the show has to has to
end and they're like why you have a mic
and I'm like yeah you're right why do we
have to cancel it and they're like I
don't know and so I'm like it let's
just do this right now and the crowd was
so amazing it like powered me through
the set at no point was I having fun I
was just like I want to put on the best
possible show for these people who
stayed